[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
la Cour des comptes dans son dernier
rapport préconise la réduction du nombre
de communes et notamment les plus
petites d'entre elles les gouvernements
successifs par le biais de différentes
lois se sont attaqués régulièrement au
nombre de communes en France toutefois
je tiens à rappeler que le fait comme
une fait des partenaires précède le fait
républicain la loi de
1971 dites-lois Marcelin a voulu faire
fusionner les communes sans grands
succès et d'autres lois similaires ont
été votées par la suite j'ajouterai que
comme on n'est pas prophète en son pays
monsieur marceelin a fait 0 fusion
association dans son département
par exemple dans mon département par
contre la Haute-Marne avec cette loi 200
communes ont souhaité au départ fusionné
mais la moitié d'entre elles ont divorcé
l'année suivante aujourd'hui les
communes sont attaquées sous l'angle
financier afin d'assainir les finances
publiques de l'État en se basant sur les
chiffres de 2021 année paradoxal où les
investissements des collectivités ont
été très réduits à cause de la crise
covid monsieur le ministre bien que ce
que de la ce que dit la Cour des comptes
soit rarement entendue par les
gouvernements quel est votre position
sur l'analyse de ce qu'elle préconise
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Bruno
à l'évocation du fait que ce Marcelin
n'a pas été prophète en son pays je veux
convoquer la présidente de roche le
sénateur pied-noir le sénateur Bigot et
le sénateur Emmanuel capuc puisque le
département du Maine-et-Loire et celui
dans lequel il y a eu le plus de fusion
de communes 48% des communes ont
fusionné au point qui nous reste 186
communes sur les 358 que nous avions
mais quand je vous aurais précisé qu'il
ne s'agit quand je vous aurais précisé
qu'il ne s'agit que de mariage d'amour
et que je vous aurais dit qu'en matière
de fusion je ne crois pas au mariage qui
ne sont pas des mariages d'amour je vous
aurais précisé ce qui est une partie de
ma philosophie en pensant qu'il faut pas
plaquer un modèle national sur ces
sujets les constats on les connaît les
constats c'est d'expliquer que nous
avions en 1790 44000 communes que nous
n'en avions que nous en avions encore 38
000 en 1960 et qu'on est rendu que à
34000 et qu'il n'y a eu que 235 fusions
de communes depuis 2014
pourtant un certain nombre de PPL je
pense à la PPLC je pense à la PPL Gatel
ce sont les forcés de regarder comment
donner un statut aux communes associées
aux communes déléguées pour éviter que
ce soit tout ou rien
notre conviction et j'associe Dominique
Faure dont vous savez l'attachement aux
communes en particulier aux communes
rurales en particulier c'est que rien
dans ce domaine ne se fera par la
contrainte
l'intercommunalité est une chance à
condition qu'on ait les conférences des
maires et les packs de gouvernance dans
certains cas il faut rendre possible les
fusions en montrant ce qu'elles
permettent mais il ne faut pas qu'elle
soit forcée sinon elles aboutissent à la
fin à des choses qui sont plus mauvaises
quelle doit être notre obsession c'est
faire en sorte qu'on ait des
mutualisations qui permettent
d'améliorer la vie des habitants sur le
territoire et le meilleur usage des
deniers publics dans certains endroits
ça peut passer par des fusions dans
d'autres par des coopérations
intercommunales dans d'autres encore par
des modes d'association qui dépendent de
ce que les élus veulent on peut pas à la
fois expliquer qu'on leur fait confiance
et projeter un modèle qui serait le même
partout en faisant fille de notre
histoire et de nos réalités locales
monsieur
aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre des
Français sont plus que jamais attachés
alors commune la crise des gilets jaunes
la crise sanitaire sont passées par là
et ont démontré l'importance de ces 500
000 élus qui travaillent qui
administrent leurs communes les maires
et leurs adjoints les conseils
municipaux bien souvent tous ces élus
sont bénévoles et font même beaucoup les
travaux à titre gracieux rappelons-nous
ce couple mère préfet le premier
ministre Jean Castex vantait le mérite
des mers comme des piliers de la
République on les applaudissait pour
leur implication mais aujourd'hui face
au poids des finances publiques on
voudrait les sacrifier je voudrais vous
dire Monsieur le Ministre que votre
réponse ne va pas convaincue alors je
repose ma question allez vous faire
payer aux petites communes le laxisme
budgétaire du gouvernement en les
supprimant
merci